facciamo fratello lui sta identica le
braccia fa male alla schiena muoversi
così ecco bravo a tutti ragazzi bella un
cazzo non sei così gnocca proprio bello
a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo io sono fa vj lei e samantha ciao
sa mi salutano fare la maleducata che si
saluta prima di cominciare inutile che
fai così niente incassato da un project
fraker sì che sarebbe una roba strana
facciamo la modalità orda che ragazzi
devo sopravvivere andatevi nemici almeno
questa è una roba un po più easy
spiegatemi il senso di questo gioco ma
[ __ ] è non funzionano all'episodio
in testa talenti locali su per il pene
che non spara mi incazzo una lattina
certo affanculo [ __ ] di morire tua
madre anche
e vabbè ma chi cazzo sono ragazzi
ok no è no è no prendi sta roba veloce e
voi da dove cazzo spuntate io non ho
visto niente se di tackle tela restando
fermo per cortesia mi fai straw favore
ti prego no niente si deve muovere
perché se non c'è la mamma the di puzza
un pò gay è morto bravo inglobate v che
adesso ci penso io
ci vuole come ci sono beni chiamati
fatti accoltella bravo fa è morto vabbè
dai ci avete provato tu stai fermo fermo
ho detto fermo mi tocca sono morto si
tocca sono morto a cazzo è successo
marco coltello a marzo fratello c'è una
roba pazzesca ribelle che è un'ondata
sola che ho fatto ce ne facessi 2000 gli
attivissimi non è facile gwis il io devo
fare da bere la faccia supera la prima
ondata un martello sono torno la carta
igienica grazie a dio a eccolo bastarda
infatti vedere samantha samantha cosa
fai
samantha giu fantasies devi stare giù oh
mio dio quanto sei bella samantha la
scotta mi guarda mi guarda mi faccia
bambino muore ragazzi non crepa aiuto
come fuori ma [ __ ] sentite mi son
rotto il cazzo è stato bello sfacio sar
mai non ho capito bene il senso di sta
roba comunque un gioco horror che sembra
fatto abbastanza bene
ovviamente non sappiamo come ci siamo
finiti in questa cosa ah ecco si
chiarisce tutto eravamo in un cesso
solo che manca al cesso si può uscire
ammesso lo stesso robbie che c'è gente
che brutta è che corre io c'ho un
accendino e o da accendere se vuoi
fumare non so e chiedo sei nudo quindi
non fare movimenti brutti scalta zio è t
dopo l'attacco di giganti sto tizio
scotto zio e o un accendino
porca la [ __ ] iniziato perché te la
prendi con l'erba che cosa ha fatto
l'air 90 c è non soccorrere è un
problema mi sta seguendo un maniaco
sono morto quindi ragazzi spero che ai
video vi sia piaciuto e come al solito
servillo è piaciuta vabbè dai bello mi
piace ciao zia alla c'è gente nuda
questa cosa abbiamo chiarita ma cosa
serve stacco ciò delle pistole a salve
sette giorni qualcosa del genere non so
tu sei bella zie un po di meno di
eyeliner andiamo avanti perché ancora un
coltello temi andare un attimo a
prendere a coltellate da allora senti
zio mi stai sul culo perché è ovvio come
le date voi le coltellate così
ragazzo sei un genio del combattimento
corpo a corpo fatelo dire da una
stagione che sono morto ma si può essere
più [ __ ] dico si sa in tv e mi
serve il coltello fatemi usa resto
coltello che non ho capito l'ho preso
l'ho presa è morto è perché è diventato
un busta delle gambe sexy a di è dir
poco credimi da altri ragazzi se premo
il tasto destro zoom con con gli occhi
c'è lui c'è lo zoom incorporato nel
cervello bellissimo così le pasticche a
me mancava solo questo munizioni per la
pistola avessi una pistola sarebbero
utili se non posso infilarmi di tutti
nel culo che con ha lasciato la tv è
accesa a sei stata tu brutta stronza
dirlo perché uno ovviamente si siede
sulla sedia riguarda il per il panorama
che veramente figo qualche bel tramonto
romantico bacheche che storia denti zia
guarda quel tramonto e solo per noi
vorrei volevo dirtelo ma si è scaricata
la torcia illuminiamo con il nostro
amore a parte le munizioni ragazzi ci
avete delle piste il carrello dell'ikea
ragazzi qualcuno a una pistola qua
dentro permesso a salve ma tipo una roba
di io sono leggenda quando entri nelle
case ci sono i cosi bruttini io sono
leggenda avevano un fucile io non ho un
cazzo alve permesso ancora cos'è stai
davanti allo schermo carica la tua
coscienza carico anche il problema è che
non ho la connessi c'è la fibra le
frecce devo diventare katniss scatola di
cracker ragazzi sono salvo zio 6 su
facebook ti fai dei self i ti faccio il
flash
così ecco vengono meglio anche quanto
sei bello cioè la pistola perché parte
lo chiedo è non hai il pene fratello
ancora una regola
ragazzi siamo a silent hill
la sirena risalenti il patto con gli
stock di capire samantha è che piacere a
noi è andata via voluta [ __ ] dove cazzo
il machete ragazzi col machete e faccio
i culi fatemi testa realtà io devo solo
provarlo devo solo
eccola fermo mai fermo
cambia niente facile ace tenuta stati
hanno il pene dritto
cosa fanno e tipo un documentario costo
uomo ed efficiente camminava su due
gambe a stento e quando trovava la sua
donna cambiava completamente direzione
eccoli ecco che vado accoppiarsi e la
donna scappa o wanda di gruppo l'albero
o la donna scappa una storia d'amore
sempre comunque migliore di twilight
guardali che fanno i tre la prima tappa
in ventuno crepo sono già convinto
permesso sento tipo qualcuno che
l'alitosi comunque comodo mettere un
tavolo così come ci passano le persone
che vanno a giugno è una roba di è una e
una tragedia ciao come stai zio è
arrivato anche un messaggio e risponde
tour abbraccia mosè ma è anche quasi
ucciso lurido stronzo
sì io ti ringrazio è stata una roba è
tragico trovare pistola li sto gioco ma
ce l'abbiamo fatta magari poi sparo ed è
scarica ma non lo so anno fa continuate
a farvi le seghe in treno del problema
cazzo ragazzi già faccio ma è andato
alla pistola per cosa regalargli una se
non spara io non mi toccare che ti
denuncio non ci sono non c'è niente bene
me ne vado grazie l'uomo corpulento si
si è mai suoi simili e quanti cazzo di
simili a bengasi le famiglie in città
c'è qualcuno che per caso accoglie ha
voglia di un avete una torta verona
disorganizzati a cazzo inglobate via
vicenda io vado di sopra
e stato bello trovato un missile
[Musica]
santissimo benedetto mi hanno inglobato
a caso ragazzi concluso qui l'episodio
non toccherò mai più un gioco horror del
genere ma neanche se mi dà regalano le
pistole è perchè tanto non sparano
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
concluso che l'episodio perché non si
può andare avanti così è un oltraggio
qualsiasi altro videogame nel mondo e
quindi ragazzi se il video è piaciuto ma
se lasciato momento mi piace è un altro
mi piace perché samantha che credo che
se di meriti se anche la pace di
facebook e come una di video platanesi
iniziata se questi dispiace ci vediamo
al prossimo video veda ragazzi